thank you
the Trojan War arguably one of Greek
mythology's largest and most significant
events some of its most epic battles
between its greatest heroes and yet if
someone was to ask me to summarize the
Trojan War I'd shrug my shoulders and
probably walk away it's a confusing
series of events with conflicting goals
infighting and just general confusion
unfortunately we do not have an
overarching text that details the events
of the Trojan War it's split into
various different texts poems and
passages we do however have some
detailed accounts from epic such as
Homer's Iliad and Virgil's Aeneid that
allow us to patch together a somewhat
coherent story hopefully today I'll be
able to fill in the gaps and explain the
events that took place
before we continue a quick word from
today's sponsor kamikoto knives
preparing food can be a pain especially
when the tools at your disposal are not
very good kamikoto knives are made from
the finest Japanese steel using only
steel that has been sourced from
Japanese meals kamikoto uses techniques
that date back to the Edo period and
every one of their knives goes through a
19-step process that can take several
years from start to finish this results
in meticulously crafted knives with
polished and sharpened edges that just
can't be matched by a regular knife
kamikoto knives are individually
inspected to make sure they reach the
high standards one expects from Japanese
steel they are so confident in the
quality of their knives they offer a
lifetime guarantee and they Pride
themselves on excellent customer service
from the creation of their knives to
Quick clear and concise response answers
to customer queries kamikoto are also
the knives of choice for Michelin star
chefs all around the world all of this
sounds great so far but what about my
experience now I'm no connoisseur when
it comes to kitchen knives but I can say
they were easily the sharpest and the
highest quality knives I've used before
the heavy duty Ashwood box that they
come in makes them an ideal gift and
this year they were my Mother's Day gift
of choice now of course you may find
yourself trying to slice your way
through random objects to see how good
these knives really are but take it from
my experience there isn't much that
survives this test if your interest has
been peaked kamikoto are offering my
viewers a Black Friday sale where you
can receive an extra fifty dollars off
your order when using the code mythology
and fiction you can also visit
kamikoto.com
mythology and fiction to help support
the Channel
simply put the Trojan War took place
between the Mycenaean Kingdom and the
kingdom of Troy the Mycenaean Kingdom
were also referred to as the acadians or
Acadian Greeks which for anyone already
confused just meant primitive or ancient
Greeks for the sake of avoiding
confusion there were Greek Heroes and
soldiers who fought on both sides but
those who sided with Troy I'll just be
referring to as Trojans the Greeks or
achaeans will be the terms used for
those who sided with Greece against Troy
the war itself took place because of the
Abduction of the Spartan Queen Helen by
the Trojan Prince Paris however to fully
understand how these events transpired
we have to go much further back as far
back as the prophecy that stated Zeus
would be overthrown by one of his
children when Zeus and Poseidon first
saw the beautiful nymph of the sea
thetas they were both more than
entertained at the idea of making her
their bride however they both
reconsidered after hearing the prophecy
surrounding thetas and her son her son
was fated to be stronger than his father
he would possess a weapon stronger than
Zeus's Thunder and Poseidon's trident
Zeus not wanting to be overthrown by his
son decided that fetus would instead
marry King peleus their son would still
possess great power but nothing to rival
Zeus and Poseidon for those wondering
this sun was indeed Achilles who would
play his own part in the Trojan War Zeus
had planned a mighty feast and
celebrations that anyone of any note or
importance was invited to the only deity
be not invited to these celebrations was
Eris the goddess of Discord and strife
in hindsight we know this completely
backfired and placed into motion the
events that caused the Trojan War
is turned up to the celebrations with a
gift in hand and she was essentially
turned away at the door as instructed by
Zeus unsurprisingly she was rather angry
at being denied entry whilst at every
other day as he enjoyed the hospitality
she took her gift which was a golden
apple and threw it amongst the guests
before turning around and leaving the
Apple was inscribed with the message to
the fairest which one would assume was a
wedding gift for the bride however the
Apple had fallen between Athena Hera and
Aphrodite the three goddesses began to
argue each one claiming the Apple was
intended for them as they were the
fairest looking for a resolution they
soon turned to the crowd who wisely
chose to not take aside eventually they
took this dispute to Zeus and asked him
to decide who was the fairest of the
three Zeus also not wanting anything to
do with this had Hermes take the three
goddesses to Mount Ida where they would
be judged by a young Shepherd this
Shepherd was Paris a prince of Troy Zeus
in a hurry to pass the buck to the next
unfortunate individual had told Paris he
could decide the winner of this beauty
contest any way he saw fit when Paris
was ready all three goddesses undressed
so he could see them naked this resulted
in another stalemate with Paris
declaring they were all of identical
beauty of course this was the incorrect
answer and so we move on to the next
stage bribery all three goddesses
offered Paris something in return for
his vote Hera offered him status as well
as the the very small ownership of the
entirety of Europe and Asia Athena
offered Paris wisdom and the skill to
match the greatest warriors in battle
Aphrodite offered him love and the most
beautiful bride on Earth Paris chose
love and declared Aphrodite to be the
fairest of all unfortunately Aphrodite
failed to mention that this beautiful
bride was Helen of Sparta who was
already married to the King of Sparta
Menelaus if Paris wanted to marry Helen
he would have to travel to Sparta and
kidnap her there are varying accounts of
what happens next under the guise of a
diplomatic expedition to Sparta Helen
saw Paris fell instantly in love and
followed him willingly back to Troy in
other other accounts Aphrodite sent Eros
who shot Helen with an arrow causing her
to fall in love with Paris and making
the abduction slightly easier King
Menelaus was the brother of King
Agamemnon who ruled over mycenaea and
what many considered to be the entirety
of ancient Greece it wasn't difficult to
convince him to join his cause and wage
war against Troy until Helen was
returned it doesn't however explain the
sheer numbers and heroes the Greeks were
able to Rally this ties back to Helen
and her father Helen was considered the
most beautiful woman across ancient
Greece and so she had many suitors
chasing her hand in marriage under the
advice of Odysseus Helen's father
convinced all these suitors to swear an
oath that despite whoever he chooses to
marry his daughter they will always
fight for Helen's honor with Helen's
disappearance her father invoked the
oath and so Menelaus had almost the
entirety of ancient Greece from its
Kings generals and heroes at his
disposal to try and return Helen to
Sparta Troy was a very prosperous and
well-fortified City ruled by King Priam
who along with his wife hecuba had over
50 Children whilst hecuba was pregnant
she had a nightmare where she gave birth
to a flaming torch as weird as it sounds
it was important enough for her to
explain to a Seer known as asicus who
also happened to be one of her children
he interpreted the dream or nightmare to
mean the prosperity and good fortune of
Troy would come to an end the flaming
torch was symbolic of the burning of
their Homeland and the fall of Troy on
the day the child was born asakus saw
visions of a royal child of Troy
responsible for its end this child was
Paris the Sears and Priests looked to
Apollo for guidance and the only way to
save Troy was by killing the child
however once Paris was born priyam and
hecuba couldn't bring themselves to kill
their child instead Priam gave him to
his head Shepherd agules and asked him
to kill the child the shepherd also
couldn't bring himself to kill the child
and so he took him to Mount Ida hoping
the Wilderness and elements would take
care of him Paris was nursed by a female
bear and so starvation was no issue
after seven days a young Paris returned
to agaleas stunned that the boy hadn't
perished he would raise him as his own
he took Priam a dog's tongue as proof
that the deed had been done pair Paris
began to establish himself as more than
just a regular Shepherd fighting off a
gang of Bandits trying to steal cattle
and returning them to their owners
before long he had earned the name Paris
Alexander a surname that meant protector
of men amongst agules heard Paris had
found the strongest Bull and challenged
the Shepherds to try and best his Bull
with one of their own none could do so
and so he extended his invitation to
anyone in Greece claiming he would give
a Golden Crown to anyone who could this
challenge was accepted by the god de
Ares who transformed himself into a bull
and defeated paris's Bull with ease
Paris was a man of his word and gave
Ares the Golden Crown as promised to the
gods this established him as an honest
man which is why when they needed
someone to judge a certain beauty
contest Zeus had no hesitation in
turning to Paris having heard his
reputation as an honest man so those
were the events that transpired and
ultimately caused the Trojan War however
this war took place over many years it
wasn't just one or two battles the
Greeks couldn't just endlessly keep
throwing their armies at the Trojans
despite having the numbers in their
favor the city of Troy was an
impenetrable Fortress its walls were
built by Apollo and Poseidon as
punishment for their Rebellion against
Zeus he sentenced them to years of hard
labor and part of this consisted of
building and fortifying the walls of
Troy the war is usually broken down into
smaller battles and skirmishes that
lasted around 10 years into terms of who
sided with who Agamemnon had amassed a
massive Army from all the major regions
in Greece Sparta Athens Crete Corinth
Arcadia Rhodes and several other cities
and states we don't have an exact number
for the total Army but it said the
Greeks sailed thousands of ships to Troy
Homer's description was even so there
are many tribes poured forth from ships
and Huts into the plane of scamander and
the Earth echoed wondrously beneath the
tread of men and horses so they took
their stand in the flowery Mead of
scamander numberless as the leaves and
flowers in their season this is often
simplified as there were as many men as
the leaves and flowers in the springtime
pretty much Homer's way of saying the
Greeks had a very big army the Greeks
also had some very iconic Heroes on
aside Achilles Ajax diomedes and
Odysseus are just a few of the more
recognizable ones
Odysseus upon learning that taking part
in the Trojan War would mean being away
from his home for 20 years tried to
feign insanity but upon his lie being
unraveled he had no choice but to answer
the cause of Greece king Menelaus and
Odysseus attempted The Diplomatic
approach and tried to negotiate the
return of Helen but they were met with
no interest from Troy and so war was the
only option after essentially being
rejected by Paris Athena and Hera both
sided with the Greek army playing
important roles assisted by Hermes
Poseidon fetus and Hephaestus Aphrodite
naturally sided with Paris and the
Trojans as well as having assistance
from a Hollow Artemis and Aries they
also had some formidable fighters of
their own Hector being the most feared
at the time he was compared to the
demigods despite this not being true
it's still a fairly good reflection of
Hector's reputation Zeus occasionally
interfered where he saw fit but for the
most part preferred to remain neutral
and his army gathered at the Port Town
of orlis where all the kings and
Generals would send for their armies to
honor their oath the king of Crete Ida
menaeus requested Agamemnon made him his
co-commander and in exchange he would
gladly send the full force of Crete to
support the war on Troy another of
agamemnon's commanders was Achilles who
at this point was only 15 years old but
had already earned the respect of his
peers and fear of his enemies before
leaving Orla say sacrifice was made to
Apollo The Seer calcus who had a very
strong connection to the god interpreted
the results to mean that Troy would
indeed fall but only after 10 years of
war the Greek set sail and landed in my
Seer mistaking it for Troy once on the
shore The Siege began which resulted in
many casualties for the natives
including their King telephus who was
almost killed by Achilles mysia were
allies of Troy and their king would
surely possess some knowledge in how to
sack the city he was taken back to all
this as a hostage at the very least they
could have him plot the correct course
to try back in all this King telephus
refused to cooperate with Agamemnon
until the spear wound he suffered from
Achilles was healed eventually Achilles
agreed to remove the shards of Spear and
telephone showed the Greeks how to reach
Troy Agamemnon was now faced with a new
issue every time they set sail from all
this they were met with extreme winds
that dispersed the fleet and made
reaching Troy together impossible they
turned to The Seer calcus once again for
answer is he was told that the winds
were punishment from Artemis because
Agamemnon had killed her sacred deer the
only way to appease Artemis was by
sacrificing his own daughter ephogenia
naturally he refused at first however
now facing a mutiny and the possibility
of a new Commander taking his place he
had no option but to accept just before
Agamemnon sacrificed ephogenia Artemis
intervened and swapped his daughter for
a lamb ephogenia became a priestess of
Artemis and with agamemnon's commitment
and loyalty proven she would allow their
fleets to finally set sail and begin
their Voyage to Troy
this back and forth from Alice and mycia
with the winds blocking and dispersing
the fleet went on for a significant
amount of time some sources say it was
several years and others go as high as
eight so the 20 years away from home
Odysseus was prophesized doesn't seem
too crazy seeing as this 10-year War
hasn't even begun and we could possibly
already be eight years in
the full force of agamemnon's fleet was
finally able to set sail we may not have
an exact number for the size of this
Fleet but we do have some descriptions
that give us a rough estimate Homer
describes 28 regions of Greece amassing
1186 boats each one containing 50 rowers
a few other accounts put this number at
around
1200 ships each one with a crew of 120
men historians took these numbers as
examples of minimum and maximum capacity
and they estimate the forces that sailed
to Troy would have been between 70 and
130
000 upon reaching the Trojan Beach
calcus prophesies the first archaean to
set foot on land would die this resulted
in the first Ships coming to a halt at
the shore and waiting for someone else
to make the first move in order to avoid
the prophecy Odysseus demonstrating his
guile managed to end this awkward
standoff between the achaeans make
himself appear fearless and avoid calcus
prophecy all at the same time he threw
his shield on the ground and when he
jumped off his ship he landed on the
shield technically he did not touch land
and therefore was not the first man on
the Trojan Shore next to follow was the
hero protocilius who we know was the
first man to step foot on land no one
expected the Trojans to leave their
heavily fortified City and meet the
Greeks head-on who had a vastly superior
Army expecting the invading Army to be
tired from their Voyage Hector led a
small group of soldiers who hid on the
beach waiting for their enemy's arrival
the first wave of the Cayenne troops
were certainly caught off guard and the
unfortunate protossilius who believed he
was not the first man on land was killed
by Hector this plan only worked for a
short period of time as more akaian
ships landed on the beach the Trojans
would eventually be overwhelmed Hector
was forced to pull his men back in
Retreats towards the city the first
encounter set the tone for much of the
war most of it took place outside of the
walls of Troy Hector and his men did
have one more small-scale encounter with
the akaian forces before retreating to
the city walls this time without the
element of surprise they suffered heavy
losses and had no choice but to flee the
majority of battles that took place for
the next nine years were just outside of
the city wars as the Trojans had no
choice but to surrender the remaining
land as its defense wasn't possible in
these battles the gods would intervene
as they saw fit blocking Spears and
arrows as well as creating distractions
to make retreating easier there are even
accounts of God's teleporting soldiers
away just before they were killed the
first nine years of this war consisted
of the Greeks keeping the Trojans
trapped inside their City while
systematically destroying the
neighboring cities and the allies of
Troy at times the Greeks were Their Own
Worst Enemy with many disagreements
causing them to turn on each other
palomedes was the individual responsible
for exposing Odysseus's lie about him
being insane so some ill feelings
already existed between the two with
supplies low Odysseus was sent to Thrace
to collect grain and food returning
empty-handed resulted in palomedes
questioning the usefulness of the hero
and so he told palomedes to do better if
he could palamidi's set sail and
returned with a ship full of grain which
of course angered Odysseus to the point
where in one story
Odysseus and diomedes drowned the
palomedes whilst he was fishing an
alternate story has Odysseus plant to
gold in palomidi's quarters and then
Forge a letter from King Priam to
palamedes making it appear as if he
betrayed the Greeks to the Trojans for
gold Agamemnon wouldn't tolerate such
treachery and so palamides were stoned
to death the lack of food and supplies
was enough to cause a mutiny from the
entire Army threatening to sail back to
Greece a combination of Achilles and
Agamemnon enlisting the three daughters
of Aeneas ended the Mutiny the daughters
were able to turn anything they wanted
into wine wheat and oil so the supply
issue was no longer affecting morale
I'm sure what many have been waiting to
hear about were the battles themselves
and the individual skirmishes early on
in an attempt to end this war fairly
without any more Bloodshed there was a
duel agreed between Menelaus and Paris
the prize being Helen they picked up
their Spears and Drew lots to see who
would be first Paris winning here took a
step back and threw his spear Menelaus
lifted his shield and blocked what was a
rather tame throw he then returned the
favor with far more aggression splitting
paris's shield and piercing his armor
Paris was lucky that his attempt to
dodge the spear resulted in a non-fatal
wound Menelaus seeing his chance charged
towards Paris swinging his swords so
hard it shattered against paris's helmet
he then grabbed Paris by the helmet and
dragged him around the battlefield in
front of his men sensing an easy Victory
Aphrodite watching on refused to let
Paris die wrapping him in a cloud he
sent him back to the city before
Menelaus could finish the job
diomedes was the youngest of the Greek
Kings to join the war to many he was
second only to Achilles in terms of
skill in combat and his bravery Homer's
Ilia doesn't cover large portions of the
war outside of the key battle and final
stages but diamedes is a name that
appears perhaps the most of all the
heroes that took part in the war what
sets diomedes apart from the other
Heroes was his wisdom and tactical
knowledge he played a huge role in the
battles themselves but also played a
large role behind the scenes in planning
and strategizing in a sparring contest
with Ajax the two tested each other's
limits even the men watching called for
the contest to come to an end in fear
that one would be seriously harmed Ajax
presented diomedes with a long sword as
a prize given he was able to draw First
Blood in their Spa diomedes was Athena's
favorite hero and he was the only mortal
or demigod other than Heracles to harm
an Olympian deity during many battles
diomedes ran through the Trojan ranks
with ease and almost caused them to
retreat single-handedly he had been
emboldened by the cause of Athena as her
Champion his shield and helmet would
glow with fire diomedes had slain
numerous Trojan Heroes including several
of King priam's sons
in one Skirmish Apollo stirred the
Trojan troops and they remained on the
battlefield the Trojan Warrior panderers
threw his Spear and wounded diamedes in
the shoulder panderas posted that he had
just killed the mighty diamede son of
tideus he was too busy celebrating to
see diomedes remove the spear and begin
walking over diomedes threw pandoras's
spear back at him and the celebration
stopped as he instantly died in front of
diomedes was Aeneas the son of Aphrodite
without any weapons diomedes grabbed a
large Boulder and hold it ateneus
crushing the hero's hip he also fell to
the ground Aphrodite intervened just in
time and was able to rescue her son
before she was able to Retreat diomedes
through pandoras's spear once again and
grazed Aphrodite's and this drew blood
and she dropped her son and fled she
took this dispute to Zeus infuriated
that a man would dare to attack her Zeus
refused to intervene claiming that acts
of War and the Affairs of man were the
responsibilities of Ares and Athena
Apollo stepped in between diomedes
andanius heeding him to listen to Athena
and stop his attacks Against The Gods
diomedes attacked Apollo numerous times
without any success an enraged Apollo
reminded diamedes he was no match for
the gods and another attack would result
in his death Apollo retreated with the
wounded Aeneas he urged Ares and Hector
who had just joined the battle to make
diomedes pay for his disrespect diamede
seeing the God of War pulled his men
back and began a slow Retreat Hera and
Athena seeing the achaeans in need of
aid offered their assistance Athena took
a chariot and using the helmet of Hades
was able to cloak herself convincing
diomedes to attack Aries they charged
towards him Aries only saw diomedes and
through his spear Athena was able to to
catch the spear aimed at diomedes and
guided diomedes when he threw his own
spear the spear Court Aries in the
abdomen the God let out a cry as loud as
a thousand men and had no choice but to
retreat from the battle diamedes had now
wounded two Olympians in one day and
slain countless Trojan Heroes and
Soldiers the Trojans were so scared of
diomedes they even made a substantial
offering to Athena pleading for her to
break his spear an offering she
unsurprisingly declined with the tide
starting to turn in the akaian's favor
Zeus declared on this particular day all
deities must Retreat from Troy and allow
the men to resolve their issues
unimpeded as the gods left Zeus conjured
a mighty storm and rained down lightning
upon the Acadian Army all the kings and
heroes jumped on their horses and tried
to escape the storm Nestor was left
behind because his horse had been
wounded by Paris diomedes noticing
Nestor missing turned around and went
back to rescue him the achaeans took
this as a sign that Zeus had sided
against them and perhaps the war was no
longer worth fighting even Agamemnon
began to question if he could lead this
Army to victory Zeus had sent an eagle
as a sign of good faith and diomedes was
the only one to notice he convinced the
achaeans that they had been prophesied
to win this war and Zeus's involvement
would not change this throughout the war
diomedes was the akaian backbone he was
the first to volunteer and the last to
retreat without him the war would have
been difficult maybe even impossible
with Hector being one of the Trojan's
most formidable Heroes and Fighters he
does appear several times throughout the
war one of the events that sparked a
series of deaths in the war was the
death of patroclus a childhood friend of
Achilles patroclus convinced Achilles to
allow him to lead a small group of men
to repel the Trojan forces trying to
destroy their ships Achilles agreed and
gave him the armor his own father had
given him so he could impersonate
Achilles and strike fear into the Trojan
forces this plan was a success with
patroclus mowing through the Trojans
with ease however he became overzealous
the Trojans retreated from the ships but
patroclus continued to chase reaching
the gates of Troy here he killed more
Trojan soldiers even killing demigods
and Sons of Zeus such as sarpadon Apollo
was able to distract patroclus long
enough for him to be hit by a spear
weakened he was then killed when Hector
took the spear and stabbed him in the
abdomen believing he had just killed
Achilles when Achilles had heard the
news along with Ajax and Menelaus they
rode out to collect his Fallen friend's
body Achilles wouldn't allow the burial
of his friend until his ghost appeared
to him and demanded a burial to allow
him to pass to the underworld if the
Trojans feared Achilles before they
would now have to deal with a much
angrier Achilles who was looking for
vengeance
Hector then had two more encounters with
Ajax who is also known as Ajax greater
the first of which was a duel that
lasted almost an entire day Ajax had the
upper hand knocking down Hector with a
large Rock and wounding him with a spear
however Zeus intervened calling the doll
a draw as it had gone on for long enough
each Warrior gave the other a gift Ajax
gave Hector a purple belt and in return
received a sword the second encounter
was when Hector and his men attacked the
Greek ships Ajax again held a large
rocket Hector and almost decapitated him
luckily Apollo was there to heal and
restore Hector Ajax took his mighty
Spear and with most of the Greek army
asleep he fought off this Trojan attack
by himself Achilles in dispute with
Agamemnon refused to assist
Ajax was eventually disarmed by Hector
with some slight intervention from Zeus
and was forced to retreat hexa and the
Trojans had only managed to burn down
one ship and had suffered heavy losses
but it was clear who Zeus favored
between the two Hera was able to
distract Zeus for long enough that
Poseidon could intervene making the
Greeks aware of this attack so they
could assist Ajax it was Achilles who
would take the bigger scalp and put an
end to the biggest thorn in the Greek
side Hector when he killed patroclus
Hector stripped him of the legendary
armor and gave it to his men to take
back to the city however there was some
descent hexa had just killed a boy and
not the mighty Achilles he had been
bested by Ajax in their eyes and refused
to challenge him there were shouts of
cowardice and so Hector put on Achilles
armor and rallied his men men claiming
that it would now make him Invincible
seeing him Don the armor and make these
claims were foolish to Zeus and he could
foresee Hector's demise the newly
emboldened Hector waited outside to
challenge Achilles however he had a
change in mind and tried to flee
Achilles gave Chase but it was Hector's
brother that cleared his mind and
prepared him for the duel the trick is
that this brother was actually Athena in
Disguise feeding him delusions of
grandeur of what he would become when he
defeated Achilles Hector made only one
request the Victor was to return the
other one's body for burial
the fight began with Achilles charging
towards Hector and hurling his spear
Hector was just able to move out of the
way Athena watching took the spear and
instantly placed it back in Achilles
hand without anyone noticing wearing the
helmet of Hades she was still invisible
hexa then threw his spear but achilles
parried with his shield he turned to his
brother to supply him with another spear
however Athena's trickery had worked as
there was no one there instead he drew
his sword knowing that his fate had been
decided Achilles could see that hexa's
collarbone was exposed and through his
spear finding the weak spot hexa fell to
the ground and with the time he had left
pleaded with Achilles to allow him an
honorable funeral Achilles told him he
would allow the dogs and vultures to
devour his flesh which after what
happened to Patrol vocalists makes sense
hexa died but not before prophesizing
that Achilles would also die soon using
the belt given to Hector by Ajax he tied
the corpse to his Chariot by the feet
and then proceeded to drag the corpse
across the city showing the Trojans how
easily he had just slain their most
feared Warrior he continued to drag the
body around for 12 days which prompted
Apollo and Aphrodite to intervene
enchanting the body and preserving it
from receiving it any more damage after
12 days the gods agreed Achilles had had
enough fun and it was time to return the
body they sent Iris and the thetas to
relay the message thesis visited her son
and persuaded him to allow King Priam to
come and claim his son's body Iris did
the same explaining the terms to the
Trojan King King Priam agreed to go
alone and retrieve his son's body but
Hermes gave him a charm that made anyone
who looked at him fall asleep making
passage much safer Achilles surrendered
the body to King Priam for the agreed
Ransom and a 12-day truce was called
between the two sides whilst funeral
rites were administered
with the truce over Achilles continued
his Trojan bloodbath outside of the city
but even the great Achilles had a
weakness when he was born thetas took
her son and made him almost Invincible
by dipping him in the river sticks the
only part of his body that was not
submersed was the heal his mother held
him by making this the only vulnerable
part of his body outside the gates of
Troy Paris took aim at Achilles and
fired an arrow Guided by Apollo his
Arrow was true and struck Achilles in
his heel a wound that would eventually
kill him some poets claim that it was
Apollo disguised as Paris who fired at
the arrow
Odysseus and Ajax fought bravely to
reclaim his body and give him the burial
he deserved next to his friend patroclus
the death of Achilles caused the Greeks
more problems than just losing their
best soldier who received his armor
became a point of contention Ajax
claimed that he had slain more Trojans
than anyone else there's no denying that
Ajax was a phenomenal Warrior but his
speech making skills were lacking
Odysseus with assistance from Athena
delivered a more eloquent and convincing
argument as to why he deserved the armor
when the council voted they decided the
armor would be given to Odysseus Ajax
feeling an overwhelming amount of Shame
and disrespect killed himself a strange
and fairly underwhelming end to one of
the war's standout warriors with
Achilles and Ajax dead the Greeks began
to worry whether this war would ever end
they turned to calcus again who spoke of
Visions regarding the arrows of Heracles
without these they would not be
victorious unfortunately Heracles arrows
were in the hands of his good friend of
philoctatis who they had abandoned on
the island of lemnos during the voyage
because he had become injured
Odysseus and diomedes were dispatched to
lemnos to retrieve the arrows
Odysseus tricked philosophies into
giving him the arrows and was ready to
set sail back to Troy diomedes on the
other hand offered to bring philosophies
back to Troy with them where they could
heal his wound begrudgingly he accepted
velocities would use these arrows to
Kill Paris however on this occasion
calcus was wrong in his prediction as
the war did not come to an end he told
the achaeons the only one who knew how
Troy would fall was the Trojan Seer
helenus diomedes accepted the task and
found the Seer he told the achaeans they
would need to return the bones of King
pelops and so they did they would have
to find the son of Achilles and have him
join the war which they also did lastly
they would need to steal the Trojan
Palladium a sacred image of Athena
Odysseus and diamedes disguise
themselves as Beggars and entered the
city of Troy Helen recognized both of
them and wishing to return home she
assisted them in stealing the Palladium
Athena then appeared to Odysseus and
gave him the idea of the Trojan Horse
under his instructions the achaeans
built a giant wooden horse that was
Hollow so men could be placed inside
inscribed on the horse was the message
the Greeks dedicate this offering to
Athena for their return home implying
they were ready to return home and
wanted Athena's blessing there is no
mention of the Trojan Horse in Homer's
Iliad Virgil's Aeneid is the epic poem
that really popularized the idea of the
Trojan horse the rest of the akaian army
had abandoned their camps and set sail
to a nearby Island to make it appear as
if they had given up and returned to
Greece they placed the Trojan Horse
outside of the main gates to the city
and disappeared the Trojans seeing the
empty camps and no Greek ships assumed
that they had won the war in their
celebration they dragged the horse
inside the city when midnight came sinon
and acheon spy signaled to the nearby
Fleet it was clear for them to dock the
soldiers inside of the horse climbed out
and killed the guards they opened the
gates allowing the Greek forces inside
the city for the first time in 10 years
the city burned and the helpless
sleeping Trojans were slain in their
beds the few remaining Defenders fell
and so did the city after a long hard 10
years of war most of the Trojan airs
were killed failed the women were taken
as concubines the Priestess Cassandra
was given to Agamemnon and priam's wife
hecuba was given to Odysseus Troy
despite a noble effort in defying the
odds for 10 years was completely
destroyed almost every Trojan male was
killed and the once prosperous city was
nothing more than a pile of rubble one
thing is for certain there was only ever
going to be one real winner Zeus
after all All is fair in Love and War
[Music]